So we're here to talk about Nunchaku, and I want to ask you first, Nunchucks or Nunchako? Like, how do you say it? What does it mean when you say one versus the other? How do you use it? I don't know. I mean, everybody usually just says Nunchukes, right? Yeah.
所以我们今天来聊聊双节棍，我想先问你，是叫 Nunchucks 还是 Nunchaku？你会怎么说？叫这个名字和叫那个名字有什么区别？你怎么用它？我不知道。我的意思是，大家通常都叫 Nunchucks，对吧？是的。
That's just sort of the standard way of doing it. I say Nunchaku, I don't know, maybe just out of little reverence for the object itself and also, you know, a nod to its origin. Yeah. But yeah, Nunchucks, Nunchucks is fine. I mean, you know, we're going to be talking about this for a long time. You know, Nunchucks is going to be, it rolls off the tongue much easier. This is historian and culture critic Jeff Chang.
这只是一种标准的发音方式。我叫它 Nunchaku，我不知道，也许是对物品本身的一点敬意，同时也是对它起源的一种致敬。是的。不过，Nunchucks，叫 Nunchucks 也行。我的意思是，我们接下来要谈论这个话题很久。你知道的，Nunchucks 这个词更顺口。这位是历史学家兼文化评论家杰夫·张。
His own personal history with Nunchucks started when he was five years old. He and his brothers would watch the classic Bruce Lee movie, Fist of Fury. I grew up in Hawaii, so on a regular hot, humid day, in an afternoon watching these things and just going crazy. Fist of Fury is a 1972 Kung Fu Classic from Hong Kong dubbed in English. Bruce Lee plays a martial artist who is trying to settle the score after his famed teacher is killed by Japanese occupiers. And then there's that amazing scene in the dojo where he's just...
他与双节棍的个人不解之缘始于他五岁的时候。他和兄弟们会观看布鲁斯·李（李小龙）的经典电影《精武门》。我在夏威夷长大的，所以在一个炎热潮湿的日子里，下午看着这些电影，整个人都狂热起来了。《精武门》是1972年香港出品的功夫经典电影，配有英语配音。李小龙在片中饰演一名武术家，在著名的师父被日本占领者杀害后，他试图算账。接着就是道场里的那场精彩戏码，他……
Whenever you're ready, I'll take on any Japanese here. He comes into the dojo. and he's about to beat up all these karate men. The camera pans up, and you see all these karate fighters in a circle surrounding the lone Bruce Lee. He gets kicked and sort of rolls over, does a somersault, and comes up,
随时奉陪，这里的日本人我全接下了。他走进道场，准备痛扁所有这些空手道男。镜头向上摇，你可以看到所有这些空手道战士围成一圈，把孤身一人的李小龙包围在中间。他被踢中，然后顺势打了个滚，做了一个前滚翻，站了起来，
and he pulls out some Nunchaku, like from who knows where he had it hiding, maybe in his pants or something like that, but he pulls it out. And everybody's like, looking at each other, like, ooh, it's that. We can totally picture. it. Nunchucks whipping his villains
掏出了一些双节棍，不知道他从哪里藏出来的，也许在裤子里或者类似的地方，但他确实掏出来了。每个人都面面相觑，心想，哦，是那个。我们完全可以想象得出。双节棍横扫他的恶人
flying right and left. He is unstoppable. But it was the sound that really did it for Jeff. When you whip the stick, it's like, you know, it's just activating all these different senses. And then we would after that
左右飞舞。他势不可挡。但真正让杰夫折服的是那个声音。当你挥舞这根棍子时，就像是，你知道的，它激活了你所有的不同感官。在那之后，我们就会
go and find toilet rolls. I remember this, like, and string and tape and try to make our own little things and whack each other on the heads with it. Five-year-old Jeff didn't know it then, but that toy he made, emulating the weapon on screen whipping around Bruce Lee's body, was also a symbol of something much larger, the emergence of a new radical, political, and cultural identity forming in America. From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States in 100 objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, how Nunchucks, through sheer force of their cultural relevance, went from ancient weapon to symbol of resistance,
去找卫生纸卷。我记得这个，还有绳子和胶带，试图自己做一些小玩意儿，然后用它互相敲对方的脑袋。五岁的杰夫当时并不知道，他制作的那个玩具——模仿着在李小龙身旁挥舞的银幕武器——也是一个更大符号的象征，它象征着美国一种新的激进、政治和文化认同的萌芽。这里是由 99% Invisible 和 BBC Studios 联合出品的《美国100件历史文物》。我是罗曼·马斯。今天我们要探讨的是，双节棍如何凭借其纯粹的文化相关力量，从古代武器转变为抵抗的象征，
not only uniting Asian Americans in the fight for their own rights, but also connecting them to every other group pushing back from the margins. The story of the Nunchucks is also a bit of the story of Bruce Lee, Hollywood's first Asian American action hero, who brought martial arts to the mainstream big screen. So when does Bruce Lee, when and how does Bruce Lee first? learn to use nunchucks. Well, maybe we can go back a little bit and talk about Bruce as a martial artist. The man, the myth, the legend, Bruce Lee, was born in San Francisco in 1940, but grew up in Hong Kong, which was then under both British colonial occupation and Japanese occupation
不仅将亚裔美国人团结在争取自身权利的斗争中，还将他们与所有其他从边缘发起反抗的群体连接起来。双节棍的故事在某种程度上也是李小龙的故事，作为好莱坞第一位亚裔美国动作英雄，他将武术带入了主流大银幕。那么李小龙是什么时候，又是如何第一次学会使用双节棍的呢？好吧，也许我们可以稍微回顾一下，谈谈作为武术家的李小龙。这个男人、神话、传奇——李小龙，1940年出生于旧金山，但在香港长大，当时香港正处于英国殖民统治和日本占领之下
during World War II. But from a young age, it was obvious. This guy was a star. So Bruce was a child actor in Hong Kong. He was really good with his body, so he became the cha-cha champion of Hong Kong. He was kind of magnetic in a lot of ways. And he's at the same time living this double life. He's like fighting in the streets.
在第二次世界大战期间。但从很小的时候起，就很明显了。这家伙是个明星。所以李小龙在香港是个童星。他的身体协调性极佳，因此成为了香港的恰恰舞冠军。他在很多方面都有一种吸引力。与此同时，他过着双重生活。他在街头打架，
He just loves fighting. He's a kind of person who, I imagine, you know, like gets hit in the face as like, oh, that tasted good. Like, I'm going to get you back. And, you know, like, there's some folks who just love the taste of blood on their lips. In school, Bruce was constantly challenging. other kids, even his teachers, to fights. The trouble was, after training in Kung Fu since he was 13, he was good, too good. After one particularly brutal fight, the police showed up at his school
他就是喜欢打架。他那种人，我能想象到，你知道的，比如脸挨了一拳会觉得，哦，这感觉挺好。然后，我要还手。而且，你知道的，有些人就是喜欢嘴里有血腥味的感觉。在学校里，李小龙不断地向其他孩子甚至老师发起挑战，要求打架。问题是，自从13岁开始练习功夫以来，他很厉害，太厉害了。在一次极其残酷的斗殴之后，警察出现在他的学校，
and threatened to arrest him, and his parents were fed up. So they had to say, okay, you won't stop. We're putting you on a slowboat to America with $100 and you're going to figure it out. You're going to go back to the land of your birth and you're going to figure it out as an immigrant. But like he hits kind of a cold reality when he arrives on the shores. Yes. When he comes to the U.S., he's realizing very quickly, oh, like, I'm not in the majority anymore. It's the early 1960s. Bruce is 20 living in Seattle, an incredibly segregated city with most of the black and Asian residents crammed into just a few neighborhoods.
并威胁要逮捕他，他的父母也忍无可忍了。所以他们不得不说，好吧，你不会停手的。我们把你塞进开往美国慢船，给你100美元，你自己去想办法。你要回到你出生的地方，作为一名移民去自己闯荡。但当他抵达彼岸时，他遇到了一种残酷的现实。是的。当他来到美国时，他很快意识到，哦，我不再是多数群体了。那是20世纪60年代初。20岁的李小龙住在西雅图，这是一个种族隔离极其严重的城市，大多数黑人和亚裔居民都被挤在仅仅几个街区里。
He can't go anywhere he wants to go. But the flip side of it is that he starts meeting all of these other folks who have grown up as oppressed folks who have lived through being what it means to be a racialized minority. So he begins to identify, you know, with black folks who have been beaten by cops, Japanese Americans who have been incarcerated, poor white folks who always feel like spit upon, people who feel left out or marginalized or outcast. And I think that's what makes him decide that he wants to become a teacher to them. They ask him to teach them.
他不能去任何他想去的地方。但另一方面，他开始结识所有其他作为受压迫者长大的人，他们经历过作为少数族裔种族化的含义。因此，他开始认同，你知道的，那些被警察殴打的黑人，被监视关押的日裔美国人，那些总是觉得自己像唾沫一样被吐掉的贫穷白人，那些感到被冷落、边缘化或排斥的人。我想正是这一点让他决定成为他们的老师。他们请求他教他们。
And so at that particular point in time, he's thinking, the way that I'm going to make it in America is to open up all these Kung Fu schools. Bruce starts teaching people in the neighborhood Kung Fu. But this was not something that was done at the time. The Kung Fu schools are called Kuons in Chinatown. They were meant to produce folks who could literally make sure that business was running in Chinatown. So these are like the bouncers and the security guards. the enforcers and all kinds of legal and illegal business. Teaching anyone who wasn't Chinese was a big no-no.
所以在那个特定的时间点，他在想，我在美国立足的方式就是开办所有这些武术学校。李小龙开始教社区里的人功夫。但这在当时并不是什么常规做法。这些武术学校在唐人街被称为“馆”。它们的本意是培养那些能够切实确保唐人街商业运转的人。所以这些就像是保镖和保安。执法人员以及各种合法和非合法的生意。教任何不是中国人的外人是一个天大的禁忌。
And not only that, a Kung Fu student would only study one particular school under one particular type of person. Kung Fu, you know, was confined to these small schools in which the seafood, the teacher, had complete dominance over what was being taught. It's like if you're studying under a seafood, you're studying in that school style. But Bruce was kind of a punk. He becomes a maverick. He's somebody who's actively poking his nose and sort of sticking his finger in the eye of the old Sifus and saying, what is all of this fake hierarchy?
不仅如此，一个功夫学生通常只在某一种特定类型的人手下学习某一个特定流派。功夫，你知道的，仅限于这些小规模的学校里，在这里，师父对所教授的内容拥有绝对的控制权。这就好像如果你在某个师父手下学习，你学的就是那个学校的风格。但李小龙有点像个叛逆小子。他成了一个特立独行的人。他是一个积极爱管闲事、把手指戳进老师父眼眶里的人，他会说，这所有的虚假等级制度到底是什么？
What is this classical mess that he calls it? It just teaches you how to obey. And it doesn't teach you anything about how to fight. In a real fight, he learned that the traditional kung fu punch, while it was flashy and might look cool, was no match for the hook or the hook. the jab of a skilled heavyweight boxer. So he started adapting, taking the fast footwork of fencing a chokehold from judo, a punching pattern from boxing, and working it into his own practice. Bruce was making a name for himself, and it got the attention of a guy named Ed Parker, who was already popularizing karate in the U.S., but who now had set his sights on bringing that
他口中的这种古典陈规到底是什么？它只是教你如何服从。它根本没有教你任何关于如何打斗的知识。在真正的格斗中，他了解到传统的功夫直拳虽然花哨而且看起来很酷，但根本无法与熟练的重量级拳击手的勾拳或刺拳相匹敌。于是他开始调整适应，吸收击剑迅捷的步伐、柔道的锁喉以及拳击的组合拳，并将其融入到自己的练习中。李小龙开始崭露头角，这引起了一个名叫埃德·帕克的男人的注意，他当时已经在全美普及空手道，但现在他的目标是将这种普及推广到所有武术。
popularity to all martial arts. So he reaches out to Bruce. Hey, you got something, and why don't you come and say that something to all these other folks? You know, I'm doing this big thing in Long Beach, and Bruce says, yeah, let's do it. So in August of 1964, Parker holds a big exhibition with all kinds of martial artists performing for regular Americans. So he's bringing in judo men, jiu-jitsu men, folks from Kauai, from the islands to show Filipino martial arts. He's literally creating this sort of pan-Asian, what would come to be. be known sort of as AANHPI, right? Asian American, Native Hawaiian Pacific Islander culture, right?
所以他找到了李小龙。嘿，你有点东西，为什么不来向所有这些其他人展示一下这个东西呢？你知道的，我正在长滩举办这个盛大的活动，李小龙说，行，那就这么办吧。因此，在1964年8月，帕克举办了一场盛大的武术表演，邀请各种武术家为普通美国人进行表演。所以他请来了柔道高手、柔术高手、来自夏威夷群岛的人来展示菲律宾武术。他实际上是在创造这种泛亚裔的、后来被称为 AANHPI 的文化，对吧？也就是亚裔美国人、夏威夷原住民及太平洋岛民文化，对吧？
Ed decides to give the headliner exhibition spot to Bruce, who at this point is virtually unknown. Bruce takes the stage, 3,000 eyes on him. Straight away, he drops into his one-arm, two-finger push-ups, and starts talking. He says, you don't need a million forms and techniques. No high kicks, no twirling around, no set moves. And everybody is just gawking. They've never seen anything like it. The folks who run schools are like,
埃德决定将压轴表演的机会留给李小龙，当时的李小龙几乎默默无闻。李小龙走上舞台，3000双眼睛盯着他。他二话不说，直接做起了单臂二指俯卧撑，并开始讲话。他说，你不需要一百万种套路和技术。不需要高抬腿，不需要旋转，不需要固定的招式。所有人都惊呆了。他们从未见过这样的场面。开武馆的人心想，
you're ripping on my entire, like, training and my teachers. And then finally, Ruse demonstrates something that he's been developing for years, the one-inch punch. Bruce asks for somebody to come down from the audience. He puts that person, you know, a few inches from him. He gives a guy a pillow because he's going to need it. And then he just sort of stands there holding up his right fist
你这是在否定我的整个训练体系和我的师父。然后最后，李小龙展示了他多年来一直在研发的绝技——寸拳。李小龙请观众席上的一位观众上台。他让这个人站在离他几英寸远的地方。他给这个人一个枕头，因为他会需要的。然后他就站在那里，举起右手拳头，
and flicks his wrist and this guy flies back like 10 feet falls into a chair and the chair tips over. And the crowd goes wild. So everybody wants to know how he did that and that makes him an immediate sensation. His name starts circulating. It becomes almost legendary. He's a force that kind of can't be contained.
手腕一抖，这个人就向后飞了大约10英尺，跌落在一把椅子上，椅子也随之翻倒。人群疯狂了。所以每个人都想知道他是怎么做到的，这让他立刻成为了轰动一时的人物。他的名字开始流传开来。几乎成了传奇。他是一股无法被遏制的强悍力量。
But beyond the main stage, there was something else happening, something that was perhaps equally important. Because backstage at this exhibition is where Bruce Lee would encounter Nunchucks for the first time. It all happened when Bruce was hanging out with another fighter who had been experimenting with a weapon from Japan. He's picked up the Nunchakus, and he's backstage, and he's kind of fooling around with him. At that moment, another fighter, a master of Filipino Eskrima, and true master of this weapon, walks up to them and says, Oh, we have that in our culture. That's Tabuk Tayuk, here, give me those. And he starts doing all these kali forms with it.
但在主舞台之外，还发生了一些事情，这或许同样重要。因为正是在这场表演的后台，李小龙第一次接触到了双节棍。这一切都发生在李小龙和另一位一直在试验日本武器的格斗家闲聊的时候。他拿起了双节棍，在后台把玩着。就在那时，另一位格斗家、菲律宾棍术（Eskrima）大师、这款武器的真正大师向他们走过来，说道：“哦，我们文化里也有这个。那是 Tabuk Tayuk，来，把它给我。”接着他开始用它表演各种卡利（Kali）套路。
And I think at that particular moment, like Bruce is staring at this going, oh, wow, this is all related. And Bruce is kind of taken with it. Nunchukes themselves don't have a single definitive origin story. Most historians trace them to Okinawa, where they likely evolved from farming tools into weapons. But across Asia, people made their own versions. A weapon with no single owner, no pure lineage. That's exactly Bruce's kind of thing. A while later, Bruce would ask his new friend
我想就在那一特定时刻，李小龙盯着看，心想，哦，天哪，这些都是相通的。而且李小龙有点被迷住了。双节棍本身并没有一个单一的、确定的起源故事。大多数历史学家将其追溯到冲绳，它们很可能在那里从农具演变成武器。但在整个亚洲，人们都制作了自己的版本。一件没有单一主人、没有纯正血统的武器。这正是李小龙喜欢的类型。不久之后，李小龙问他的新朋友
if he could try Nuntrucks out for himself. Bruce tells him, hey, you know, whatever happened to those sticks, those Nunchaku things, and he's like, oh, here. And he's like, yeah, you know, like, I don't know anything about these, but this is what I would do with them. And he sort of whips them out,
他是否可以亲自试用一下双节棍。李小龙对他说，嘿，你知道的，那些棍子，那些双节棍怎么处理了？那个人说，哦，给你。然后李小龙说，是的，你知道的，我对这些一无所知，但这就是我会对它们做的事情。接着他顺势挥舞了起来，
and he's just kind of flabbergasted because Bruce has just seen this and kinetically figured out how to like mess all this stuff around. And of course, it becomes a big part of his toolkit, his arsenal, if you will, in the movies. And it's significant that it's at this exhibition that Bruce learns about Nunchucks because that event is what would launch Bruce's Hollywood career.
那个人彻底惊呆了，因为李小龙仅仅看了一眼，就在动力学上琢磨出了如何把这玩意儿耍得团团转。当然，这成了他工具箱里、或者说电影中武器库里的重要组成部分。而且正是在这次展览上，李小龙了解到了双节棍，这具有重大意义，因为正是这次活动开启了李小龙的好莱坞生涯。
The Hollywood folks who are in the audience, and there's lots of them. You know, there's actors, there's directors, there's producers, there's people who are barbers for the actors. They're just drawn to him. And it was one of these folks, a celebrity hairstylist who was responsible for Bruce's big break. This barber was going on and on about Bruce while he was cutting the hair of some big-time Hollywood producer. And he convinces the producer to consider Bruce for his next lead role, the son of Charlie Chan.
台下的好莱坞人士，人数众多。你知道的，有演员、导演、制片人，还有演员的理发师。他们都被他吸引了。正是其中的一位，一位负责李小龙重大机遇的名人发型师。这位理发师在为某位好莱坞大牌制片人理发时，对李小龙赞不绝口。他成功说服制片人在下一部主演作品中考虑李小龙，饰演陈查理的儿子。
And it would be the first Asian American male TV lead ever. So he's like, come out and try out for this part. Now, Bruce, just look right into the camera lens right here and tell us your name, your age, and where you were born. My last name is Lee, Bruce Lee. I was born in San Francisco in 1940. I'm 24 right now. Bruce comes out and does this amazing audition in which he demonstrates some Kung Fu techniques
这将是有史以来第一位亚裔美国男性电视剧主角。所以他说，出来试镜这个角色吧。现在，李小龙，请看着这里的摄像机镜头，告诉我们你的名字、年龄以及出生地。我姓李，李小龙。我1940年出生于旧金山。我今年24岁。李小龙出场了，进行了一次精彩的试镜，其中他展示了一些功夫技巧
on a hapless, older white dude. You can watch this. It's hilarious. There are various kind of stripe. To the eyes, you would use fingers. All straight at the face. At one point, he's all like, yeah, the guy's a little scared, didn't he? Don't worry? All right.
对付一个倒霉的、年长的白人老头。你可以看这个。太搞笑了。有各种各样的条纹。直击眼睛，你会用手指。直面面部。有一刻，他整个人就像是，是的，那家伙有点害怕，不是吗？别担心？好吧。
It's kind of work. And he has nothing to worry about. And it's just a scintillating type of thing. Like, clearly he's a star. But TV's not ready. TV's not ready for an Asian American male to be a lead, let alone Bruce Lee to be a lead. The network drops the Charlie Chan spin-off series completely.
这有点用。他没有什么好担心的。这真是一种精彩绝伦的表现。显然他是个明星。但电视还没有准备好。电视还没有准备好让亚裔美国男性成为主角，更不用说让李小龙当主角了。电视网彻底取消了《陈查理》衍生剧系列。
But it's not over for Bruce. The producer says, Hey, stick around. We might have another thing for you. That thing turned out to be the ABC series, The Green Hornet, where Bruce plays Cato, the sidekick to the crime-fighting Green Hornet.
但这并不意味着李小龙的演艺生涯就此结束。制片人说，嘿，留下来。我们可能还有另一个角色适合你。那个角色后来证明是美国广播公司（ABC）的系列剧《青蜂侠》，李小龙在剧中饰演加藤（Cato），即打击犯罪的青蜂侠的助手。
Bruce comes in, he gets the part, and he goes and tries to get some acting training, and he and his acting coach are looking at these scripts, and he's like, wait a minute, they didn't give me any lines, because nobody has ever imagined that Cato would ever speak. And for the vast majority of the show, Bruce was indeed silent. He's a guy who saves the Green Hornet's ass because the Green Hornet can't fight for himself. He's an executive. He sits on the back seat and he kind of tells him, Cato Drive or Cato cook or Cato like Kung Fu that guy.
李小龙进组拿下了这个角色，然后他去试图接受一些表演训练，他和他的表演教练看着这些剧本，心想，等等，他们没有给我安排任何台词，因为从来没有人想过加藤会开口说话。在绝大多数剧集中，李小龙确实都是沉默寡言的。他是一个拯救青蜂侠于水火之中的人，因为青蜂侠自己不会打架。他是个高管。他坐在后座上，指挥着，加藤开车，或者加藤做饭，或者加藤对那家伙用功夫。
And that's what Cato does. This kind of subordination, servility. This is something that Cato had inherited from earlier versions of this character. At first on the radio. An adventure of the Green Hornet. Which is an old sort of character that's kind of blandly oriental. They've never really figured out who this guy is. Originally, the writers made him Japanese.
这就是加藤所做的事。这种顺从、奴性。这是加藤从这个角色的早期版本中继承下来的东西。最初是在广播里。《青蜂侠历险记》。这是一个老旧的、带点温吞东方色彩的角色。他们从没真正弄清楚这家伙到底是谁。最初，编剧把他设定为日本人。
But then, in the lead-up to World War II, that seemed unsavory. So suddenly, Cato wasn't Japanese anymore. He was just... Cato, his faithful valet. Then the writers gave him a new identity. Cato was now... His Filipino valet Cato stepped through a secret panel in Britain. Then, in the film serials, executives made him Korean,
但在二战前夕，这看起来很不讨喜。于是突然之间，加藤不再是日本人了。他只是……加藤，他忠诚的贴身男仆。然后编剧赋予了他一个新的身份。加藤现在是……他的菲律宾贴身男仆加藤穿过了英国的一个秘密暗门。然后，在系列电影中，高管们把他变成了韩国人。
which they thought would be the least controversial of the Asian identities. But through all of this, nothing about the character actually changed. All this Orientalism, this frustrated Bruce. I mean, they're trying to get me to do too many things that are really for the sake of being exalted. He said as much in an interview he did with the Canadian broadcaster, Pierre Breton. And I mean, it's always that pigtail and bouncing around chop chop, you know, with the Iceland and all that. I have already made up my mind that in the universe. United States, I think something about the Oriental, I mean, the true Oriental should be shown.
他们认为这会是亚裔各种身份中最少引发争议的一个。但经历这一切后，角色的内核其实一点也没变。所有这些东方主义，让李小龙感到十分沮丧。我是说，他们试图让我去做太多纯粹为了炫耀而存在的事情。他在接受加拿大广播员皮埃尔·布雷顿采访时曾这样说过。我的意思是，总离不开那根辫子，还有蹦蹦跳跳的“嚓嚓”声，你知道的，还有冰岛之类的。我已经在心里做好了打算，在美国的土地上，我认为应该展现出有关东方人的真实一面。
Oriental, a word that was so universally used at the time, even Bruce was calling himself that. But meanwhile, across the country, there are kids who felt frustrated in the exact same way. Japanese, Chinese, Filipino American college students were all fed up with being lumped together by white folks in power. But unlike Bruce, they were going to organize. We're now moving into the late 1960s, and across the country, tensions are rising. And what we see is this growing anti-war movement, right? People rising up against the Vietnam War. A lot of the anti-war movement was happening on college campuses like Berkeley,
“东方人”（Oriental），这个词在当时被普遍使用，甚至连李小龙自己也这么称呼。但与此同时，在全国各地，有些年轻人感到了完全相同的沮丧。日裔、华裔、菲律宾裔的美国大学生们，都受够了被当权白人粗暴地归为一类。但与李小龙不同的是，他们打算组织起来。时间来到了20世纪60年代末，全国各地的紧张局势不断加剧。而我们看到的是日益高涨的反战运动，对吧？人们纷纷站出来抗议越南战争。许多反战运动都发生在大学校园里，比如伯克利，
where two American-born Asian students, Uji, Yiyoka, and M.O.G, had been organizing. But by the spring of 1968, they'd started to notice something. For one, there were more and more Asian folks, people who were people who were, who looked like them showing up at these demonstrations. And the more they looked around, the more disconnected they felt from the main message of the movement at the time. Young people are out on the street saying, bring the boys home.
两个美籍亚裔学生——乌吉·吉冈（Uji Yiyoka）和M.O.G.一直在那里参与组织活动。但到了1968年春天，他们开始注意到一些现象。首先，越来越多的亚裔，也就是那些长得跟他们一样的人，开始出现在这些示威游行中。然而他们环顾四周越多，就越觉得与当时运动的核心诉求产生了一种疏离感。年轻人们走上街头高喊：让小伙子们回家。
And they are looking at this, and they're saying, that doesn't seem to be what the movement should be about. We're seeing people who look like our parents just getting bombed. Their home places are being torn up. If you think about it, like, that's the reason we're here. It's not just about bringing the boys home. It's about ending American imperialism.
而他们看着这一切，心里却在想：运动的重点似乎不该只是这样。我们看到那些长得像我们父母的人正在遭受狂轰滥炸。他们的家园被彻底摧毁。如果你仔细想想，这才是我们来到这里的真正原因。这不仅仅是关于让小伙子们回家。这是为了终结美国的帝国主义。
Then they had this idea. They were organizers for this new political party, the Peace and Freedom Party, which had formed around an anti-war agenda. So they decided to look over their own party's voter registration lists to identify any Asian people who might have felt the same way. So they take their lists, they look at all the names of folks on that list, and they go, hmm, you know, that person. person's last name is Kim, that person's last name is Chang, like, that person's last name is Wong, and they're like, we should call all of them and invite them to this meeting. They bring this group of folks together, and it's, you know, it's not many folks. Six people or so show up, and they are having this discussion about how to address the war. And the conversation quickly takes
接着，他们想到了一个主意。他们是一个新政党“和平与自由党”（Peace and Freedom Party）的组织者，该党是围绕反战议程组建的。于是，他们决定翻阅自己党派的选民登记名册，找出可能也有同感的人。于是他们拿着名单，看着上面所有人的名字，然后心想：嗯，你知道的，那个人姓金（Kim），那个人姓张（Chang），就像那样，那个人姓黄（Wong），然后他们觉得：我们应该给所有人打电话，邀请他们来开个会。他们把这群人聚到了一起，你知道的，人数其实不多。大约六个人出席了，他们开始讨论如何应对这场战争。而当大家开始倾诉内心的真实感受时，谈话迅速朝着
on a new motion when folks are talking about how they actually really feel. I walk across the street and they're calling me a gook. People are like, I haven't been able to get a job for so long. I've stopped looking. And they say that they're getting beaten because people are saying, oh, that's the enemy. Go practice on him. So, you know, they're like, you know, how do we talk about this?
一个新的方向发展。有人说：“我走过马路，他们却叫我‘gook’（对亚洲人的蔑称）。”还有人说：“我好久都找不到工作了。我甚至已经放弃寻找了。”他们说自己挨打是因为别人会指着他们说：“看，那是敌人。去拿他练练手吧。”所以，你知道的，他们就在想：我们该怎么谈论这件事呢？
Like, maybe we need to be able to figure out how we can all kind of come together and have a name and UG just throws it out. UG is like, you know, don't call us Oriano anymore. That's a rug. And Oriental is a rug. We are Asians and we are from America. Then they're like, ding, ding, ding. The lights go on.
就像是，也许我们需要弄清楚，我们该如何团结起来，起一个共同的名字。这时乌吉脱口而出。乌吉说：“听着，别再叫我们‘东方人’（Oriental）了。那是块地毯。”“东方人”是一块地毯。我们是亚裔，我们来自美国。然后他们就像是：叮、叮、叮，灵光一现。
You know, everybody's like excited. And they come out and they form a group that they call the Asian American political alliance. Asian American. It seems commonplace now. But this new political identity was radical. Up until then, U.S. immigration and military policy had forced Asian people to separate themselves. by nationality as a matter of survival. Just two decades earlier during World War II,
你知道的，所有人都兴奋起来了。他们聚在一起，成立了一个组织，并将其命名为“亚裔美国人政治同盟”（Asian American Political Alliance）。亚裔美国人。现在听起来这似乎很常见。但在当时，这种新的政治身份具有极大的颠覆性。在此之前，美国的移民和军事政策一直迫使亚裔为了生存，不得不按国籍将彼此隔离开来。就在仅仅二十年前的二战期间，
Japanese Americans were being disappeared to internment camps. To distinguish themselves from the ethnically Japanese, Asian families would put signs in front of their homes and businesses that read, we are Chinese, we are Filipino, we are Korean. But now they were done with all that. That's 1968, and by 1969, there's thousands upon thousands of people all across the country
日裔美国人被强行带走并送往拘留营。为了将自己与日本血统区分开来，亚裔家庭会在他们的家门前和企业门口挂上牌子，上面写着：“我们是中国人，我们是菲律宾人，我们是韩国人。”但现在，他们受够了这一切。那是1968年，到了1969年，全美已有成千上万的人
who are using that name were Asian Americans. These kids took something that people in power had been doing to them for years, lumping them all together, regardless of nationality, under the same racist banner of Oriental. And they flipped it on its head. Now they were joining forces intentionally, on their own terms. And it was powerful, like the one-inch punch.
都在使用这个名字——我们是亚裔美国人。这些年轻人将当权者多年来对他们做的事——不论国籍，统统贴上种族主义标签“东方人”混为一谈——彻底反转了过来。现在，他们开始刻意联手，按照他们自己的方式掌握主动权。这股力量极其强大，就像李小龙的“寸拳”一样。
What's interesting is that it's already building in the culture, right? So if you look at what Bruce is doing with his friends, in terms of mixing up these different types of martial arts forms from Asia and the Pacific is heralding this new development of an Asian America. After years of frustration, the culture seemed to be changing. And it seemed to Bruce that now, just maybe, he might be able to break out of his role as the sidekick. In 1970, Bruce met with Fred Weintraub, a Warner Brothers executive who wanted him to star in a new film project, literally called Kung Fu.
有趣的是，这种文化已经在酝酿之中了，对吧？所以如果你看看李小龙和他的朋友们在做的事，他们将来自亚洲和太平洋地区的各种武术流派融合在一起，这正预示着亚裔美国人这一新身份的发展。经过多年的挫折，文化似乎正在发生变化。李小龙觉得，现在也许，仅仅是也许，他终于能够摆脱自己作为配角的命运了。1970年，李小龙与华纳兄弟的高管弗雷德·韦因特劳布（Fred Weintraub）会面，后者希望他主演一个全新的电影项目，片名直译就叫《功夫》。
Bruce, more than anybody else in the country, has popularized this martial art called Kung Fu. And he's been on TV. So all the other Asian American actors in Hollywood are like, oh, that's a lead part, but that's Bruce's part. I'm not even going to go out for that part. Bruce nails the audition. But still, the other executives in the studio are dragging their feet. They ultimately kill the idea of a Kung Fu movie. They do keep dangling the possibility of a TV series, but frustrated and worried.
李小龙比美国任何人都更普及了这种名为“功夫”的武术。而且他上过电视。所以好莱坞所有其他的亚裔美国演员都觉得：哦，那是个主角，但那是李小龙的角色。我甚至都不会去竞争那个角色。李小龙的试镜表现惊艳全场。但即便如此，片厂的其他高管还是畏缩不前。他们最终取消了制作《功夫》电影的想法。他们确实一直在吊着观众的胃口，暗示可能会推出电视剧，但这让李小龙感到沮丧和担忧。
Without an answer, Ruth decides to take a job in Hong Kong. Like Hong Kong's Kung Fu film industry at that particular time is running all of Asia. And they're like clamoring. We want that guy. We need to get that guy. He's already made it in Hollywood. He's going to definitely make it here. And they make him an offer you can't refuse.
在得不到回应的情况下，李小龙决定接受一份在香港的工作。当时香港的功夫电影产业正风靡整个亚洲。他们简直趋之若鹜。他们说：“我们要那个人。我们需要把那个人找来。他已经在好莱坞成功了，他在这里也绝对能成功。”于是他们开出了一个他无法拒绝的条件。
Finally, it's a leading role, a chance to prove his star potential to the executives in the U.S. And it is a hit. It becomes a sensation. It breaks all box office records and becomes a stunt. literally overnight. Immediately afterwards, Bruce shoots another Kung Fu movie, another smash hit called Fist of Fury. And while his star is rising in Hong Kong,
终于，这是一个主角的机会，一个向美国高管证明他票房号召力的机会。电影大获成功。它成了一种轰动现象。它打破了所有票房纪录，一夜之间成为了神话。紧接着，李小龙又拍摄了另一部功夫电影，又一部轰动之作《精武门》。正当他在香港的名气如日中天之际，
he finally gets news from Hollywood about his role in the TV show Kung Fu. He gets turned down because they say, we can't understand his accent. And, you know, Bruce has got a British accent. He just has the wrong face. And so they give the part to David Caradine, who tapes up his eyes and darkens his skin and stoops on the set and plays it in yellow face
他终于收到了好莱坞关于电视剧《功夫》角色的消息。他被拒绝了，因为他们说：“我们听不懂他的口音。”要知道，李小龙其实带点英国口音。他们只是觉得他的脸不对。于是他们把这个角色给了大卫·卡拉丁（David Carradine），他在片场把眼睛贴细、把皮肤化黑、驼着背，以“黄脸扮相”（yellow face）出演，
and just continues the tradition of how Hollywood looks at Asia. You got to imagine, this is like the role of his life. He really thought he deserved it. He feels like he played the game. He really, you know, worked with these folks and he got to know them. He trained a lot of them in Kung Fu,
这延续了好莱坞看待亚洲的固有传统。你可以想象，这就像是他一生的角色。他真的觉得自己配得上。他觉得自己融入了那个圈子。他真的，你知道的，和这些人共事并了解了他们。他在他们的家里教过他们很多人功夫，
like at their houses. And then they would do this to him and not give him this role and put a white guy into a role playing a Chinese, a half Chinese guy. After that, Bruce has had it with Hollywood. He has had it with America. He decides to stay in Hong Kong for the foreseeable future. He's like, okay, I understand. This is where I have to be. I have to be here in Asia where they can see me.
比如在他们自己的家里。然后他们却这样对待他，不把这个角色给他，反而让一个白人演员去扮演一个中国人和半中国人的混血角色。在那之后，李小龙对好莱坞彻底死心了。他对美国彻底死心了。他决定在可预见的未来留在香港。他心想：好吧，我明白了。这就是我该待的地方。我必须待在这里，待在能看到我的亚洲。
So these Hong Kong action movies, they're not just huge in Hong Kong. I mean, they're huge, huge in Hong Kong. But they make it over here. Tell me about where they thrive, how they sort of infiltrate culture here in the U.S. This is a moment where Hollywood is collapsing. You know, the old studio system that's been going strong for over half a century is showing a lot of signs of cracking. The movies Hollywood had poured millions into were flopping at the box office. The older generation was at home watching their color TVs, and the kids didn't want to watch another sound of music.
所以这些香港动作片，它们不仅在香港大火。我的意思是，它们在香港简直火得一塌糊涂。但它们也传到了我们这边。跟我讲讲它们是在哪里大受欢迎的，它们是如何渗透进美国本土文化的。这是一个好莱坞正在崩塌的时期。你知道的，那个已经强盛了半个多世纪的旧制片厂体制正显现出大量的崩溃迹象。好莱坞砸下数百万美元制作的电影在票房上惨遭滑铁卢。老一辈人在家里看彩色电视，而孩子们才不想看什么《音乐之声》。
Hello Dolly. And so what's the breath of fresh air that comes along? Well, 1971, Melvin Van Peebles independently releases this movie called Sweet, Sweet Back's badass song. And it just is a sensation. The movie follows Sweetback, a black performer at a brothel who fights back against racist police officers, and it completely shattered the way old Hollywood worked. It makes over a million dollars off a tiny, teeny, tiny budget.
还有《甜心先生》。那么，随之而来的清流是什么呢？1971年，梅尔文·范·皮布尔斯（Melvin Van Peebles）独立发行了一部名为《甜蜜的电影》（Sweet Sweetback's Baadasssss Song）的电影。它引发了巨大的轰动。影片讲述了皮布尔斯——一个在妓院工作的黑人表演者，奋起反抗种族主义警察的故事，它彻底颠覆了旧好莱坞的运作方式。它用微乎其微的超低预算，赚取了超过一百万美元的票房。
And it makes that money just. by playing in the inner cities, like in the scariest parts of America. The movie was released to gritty grindhouse theaters that played everything the mainstream rejected on a 24-hour loop. They just play Blacksportation movies. They play foreign films. They play porn movies, right? Sweet Sweet Sweetback is a classic of the Blacksploitation genre, a new form that was exploding at the time, where Black protagonists took down white authority with violence, style, and glamour. So kung fu movies come in on the heels of that.
而且这些钱全靠在内城上映赚来的，比如美国治安最可怕的那些地方。这部电影被投放到粗粝的“剥削电影院”（grindhouse theaters）里，这些影院全天候不间断地播放着主流社会所唾弃的一切内容。它们只播放黑人剥削电影。它们播放外国电影。它们播放色情电影，对吧？《甜蜜的电影》是黑人剥削电影（blaxploitation）类型的经典之作，这是一种在当时蓬勃发展的新兴类型片，片中的黑人主角以暴力、风格和魅力击垮了白人权威。所以功夫电影正是顺应了这股潮流。
Kids are coming in and they're watching these black exploitation movies. They're there for an afternoon. It's super hot. And so they're just going to watch all the movies that are playing in there. Shaft maybe comes on like and then the Chinese boxer comes on. And they're like, what is this? But it's dubbed. You know, the dubs are kind of corny and a little hilarious.
孩子们走了进来，观看了这些黑人剥削电影。他们在那里待上整整一个下午。天气超级热。所以他们干脆把里面正在播放的所有电影都看了一遍。也许接着放映的是《夏福特》（Shaft），然后《中国拳王》（The Chinese Boxer）又上场了。他们心想：这是什么？但它是配音的。你知道的，配音有点老土，甚至还有点滑稽。
And at the same time, they're kicking butt, you know? And the plot lines are pretty much the same. These are folks who are on the margins. They've been harmed. They've been disenfranchised. And they're avenging their folks against these tyrannical and corrupt bosses and politicians. So they stick around and they realize, oh, wow, these are great. In 1972, Fist of Fury opens in New York's Chinatown Pagoda Theater.
与此同时，他们在片中大显身手，对吧？而且剧情套路基本上都差不多。这些都是处于社会边缘的人。他们受到了伤害，被剥夺了权利。他们正在向那些暴虐且腐败的老板和政客复仇，为自己人讨回公道。于是他们留下来观看，并意识到：哦，天哪，这些电影太棒了。1972年，《精武门》在纽约唐人街的宝塔剧院（Pagoda Theater）上映。
And for the first time in the theater's history, half of the crowd was non-Chinese. And it's this movie where Bruce Lee gains a whole new movie. audience, a deeper layer to his fame. When Bruce first came out in the mid-60s as Cato, he wasn't a hero for the Asian-American radicals. He was just like, oh, that's another sort of guy who's going to serve his white master. But when Fist of Fury plays, a lot of those folks who were calling themselves Asian-American, they're sitting there in the theater and they're watching Bruce Lee kicking down that sign that says no dogs in Chinese aloud. And they're seeing black folks, white folks, Latino folks,
在该影院历史上破天荒地，有一半的观众都是非华裔。正是在这部电影中，李小龙收获了全新的一批观众，他的名气达到了更深的层次。当李小龙在60年代中期以“加藤”（Cato）的形象初次登场时，他并不是亚裔美国激进分子心目中的英雄。人们只会觉得：哦，那又是一个准备服侍他白人主子的家伙。但当《精武门》上映时，许多自称为亚裔美国人的人坐在影院里，看着李小龙一脚踢碎那块写着“华人与狗不得入内”的牌子，他们看到黑人、白人、拉丁裔人，
you know, American Indian folks, they're all going crazy just like they are. And so they're realizing, oh, this is a moment and this is a thing. This guy is an underdog. Like, he's fighting on our side. He's exactly what we want to see represented and to be about. By 1973, the Kung Fu movie craze is at an all-time peak. In that year alone, six Kung Fu flicks out of Hong Kong hit number one
你知道的，还有美洲印第安人，他们全都像他们自己一样陷入了疯狂。于是他们意识到：哦，这是一个历史时刻，这是一件大事。这家伙是个弱者。而且，他在为我们这一边战斗。他完全就是我们渴望看到的、所代表的那种形象。到了1973年，功夫电影热潮达到了史无前例的巅峰。仅在那一年，就有六部来自香港的功夫电影冲上了票房榜首，
the box office, and 15 more hit in the top 50 as they played in Chinatowns and segregated neighborhoods across America. Which movie encapsulates the peak of this era? I mean, to me, I think it's probably Enter the Dragon, but maybe you have a different opinion about this. No, I think Enter the Dragon is absolutely it, yeah. And the reason it does is because, you know, it comes in this year, 1973, where we're kind of at peak third world culture, if you're looking at it that way.
另有15部挤进了前50名，它们在美国各地的唐人街和种族隔离社区中上映。哪部电影最能概括这个时代的巅峰？我的意思是，对我来说，我觉得可能是《龙争虎斗》，但你对此可能有不同的看法。不，我觉得《龙争虎斗》绝对是当之无愧的。之所以如此，是因为你知道的，它正是在1973年上映的，如果我们从这个角度来看的话，当时我们正处于第三世界文化的巅峰期。
When Jeff says third world culture, he's referring to a movement where black and Asian activists, among other groups, started seeing their struggles as part of something bigger, not just a fight for rights at home, but a connection to people pushing back against power everywhere in Vietnam and Algeria and the Congo. The idea was that a so-called ghetto in Oakland had more in common with a foreign village under a colonial rule than anyone in power wanted to admit. And that feeling was everywhere in culture. One of the top albums in 1973 was called The World is a Ghetto. Bob Marley was gaining popularity everywhere. Hip-hop was literally invented that year.
当杰夫提到“第三世界文化”时，他指的是这样一场运动：黑人和亚裔激进分子以及其他群体开始将他们的抗争视为更大宏图的一部分，这不仅仅是为了争取国内权利的斗争，而是与世界各地反抗强权的民众联系在一起——从越南、阿尔及利亚到刚果。当时的观点是，奥克兰所谓的“贫民窟”与一个受殖民统治的外国村庄之间，有着比当权者愿意承认的更多的共同点。而这种感觉充斥在整个文化中。1973年最热门的专辑之一就叫《世界是个贫民窟》（The World is a Ghetto）。鲍勃·马利（Bob Marley）到处都在获得人气。嘻哈音乐正是在那一年被发明的。
We're at sort of this peak moment where folks are just looking for a different kind of hero. And that's Bruce. That's what Bruce Lee is. In Enter the Dragon, Bruce Lee teams up with Jim Kelly, a black martial artist, and John Saxon, a white martial artist, to form a multicultural fighting squad. It really is just taking everything and showing a kind of commonality, a common struggle. And, you know, it's funny because it didn't, it wasn't really planned this way. So, for instance, they chose three actors as leads because they were actually unsure that Bruce Lee was going to be able to carry a movie all by himself, right?
我们正处于这样一个巅峰时刻，人们只是在寻找一种不同类型的英雄。那就是李小龙。这就是李小龙代表的意义。在《龙争虎斗》中，李小龙与黑人武术家吉姆·凯利（Jim Kelly）和白人武术家约翰·萨克森（John Saxon）联手，组成了一个多元文化的战斗小队。这其实就是将一切融合在一起，展现出一种共通性，一种共同的抗争。而且，你知道的，这很有趣，因为这一切并不是事先计划好的。例如，他们选择三位演员担任主角，其实是因为他们不确定李小龙能否独自撑起一部电影，对吧？
So let's put a black man in there, of course, a nod to black deportation. And of course, let's put a white man in there. Whatever they intended, the movie spoke directly to the third world movement. There's an iconic scene where the black member of the trio, Jim Kelly, is riding through a harbor in Hong Kong, looking around at people living on these crammed houseboats. They don't live so big over there. Gettos are the same all over the world. They stink.
所以让我们在里面安排一个黑人，当然，这是对黑人剥削电影的一种致敬。当然，让我们再安排一个白人。无论他们的初衷如何，这部电影直接呼应了第三世界运动。有一个标志性的场景，三人组中的黑人成员吉姆·凯利骑马穿过香港的港口，环顾四周那些住在拥挤船屋里的人们。“他们在那里住得可不算宽敞。全世界的贫民窟都一样。它们都臭气熏天。”
The ghettos, all over the world, they're all the same. That's one of those lines that it's just like, What could be more third world than that particular line? And it's one of those lines that just sings down the generations. And of course, there's the incredible scene with Bruce Lee and his nunchucks, where a shirtless Bruce surrounded again on all sides takes the nunchucks from one of the men and fends off three different attackers. When Bruce is in these scenes with his nunchucks, people are just magnetized, right?
“全世界的贫民窟，它们全都是一样的。”这是那种听了之后会让人感叹的台词之一：还有什么台词能比这更具“第三世界”色彩呢？这是那些代代相传、余音绕梁的台词之一。当然，还有李小龙和他的双节棍的精彩场景，光着膀子的李小龙再次被四面合围，他从其中一人手中夺过双节棍，击退了三个不同的袭击者。当李小龙出现在这些挥舞双节棍的镜头中时，人们简直被深深吸引了，对吧？
And then the natural reaction is you're going to go out and you're going to make your own. you're going to go and buy some, you're going to try to do it yourself. And so suddenly there's all these young people, like mostly black folks and yellow folks and brown folks, just in the streets with nunchakus. In a way, the nunchucks are the perfect symbol for this moment. Here's this weapon, not born from any single nation,
而自然的反应就是你会走出去，自己也去做一个，你会去买一些，你会试着亲自去耍一耍。于是突然之间，所有这些年轻人，主要是黑人、黄种人和棕色人种，手里都拿着双节棍走上了街头。某种程度上，双节棍正是这个时代的完美象征。这件武器并非诞生于某一个单一的国家，
but a mashup of fighting traditions across Asia, one that is now being embraced by a coalition of minorities in America. It's scrappy. It's the kind of thing you pull out when you're surrounded on all sides, when you're backed into a corner. And this scares the hell out of people who are already feeling threatened by black exploitation movies and kung fu movies. They just don't want to see this image of, you know, young folks of color with weapons. Immediately after Enter the Dragon was released, officials started referring to the people who used nunchucks as muggers and members of street gangs. Mainstream outlets like the New York Times ran articles saying that they were turning up in the hands of youth across America.
而是亚洲各地武术传统的融合，如今它正被美国的一众少数族裔联盟所拥抱。它透着一股野性。这是当你四面楚歌、被逼入绝境时才会掏出来的东西。而这把那些本来就因为黑人剥削电影和功夫电影而感到受到威胁的人吓得半死。他们就是不想看到这种有色人种年轻人手持武器的形象。就在《龙争虎斗》上映后不久，官员们开始把使用双节棍的人称为“持强抢劫犯”和“街头帮派成员”。《纽约时报》等主流媒体甚至发文称，双节棍正在落入全美各地青少年的手中。
Newsweek called them killer sticks. And the following year, five states banned them entirely. Unlike laws for pocket knives or baseball bats, where police usually have to prove you intend to use them as a weapon, nunchucks were classified alongside brass knuckles and sought-off shotguns. Simply having a pair sitting in your bedroom could mean a felony charge. I was looking at the number of nunchakus that were sold on New York. And it was something, it came up to like maybe less than 3,000 a year. There was like 15 million guns that are sold a year, right?
《新闻周刊》称它们为杀人棍。第二年，有五个州完全禁止了双节棍。与对袖珍刀具或棒球棍的法律不同，警察通常必须证明你打算将它们用作武器，而双节棍则与指节铜套和短管霰弹枪归为一类。仅仅在卧室里放一副双节棍就可能意味着重罪指控。我当时在查纽约出售的双节棍数量。结果大概是每年不到3,000副。每年大约卖出1500万支枪，对吧？
So that tells you that it wasn't about the nunchakus. It was about the folks who were holding the nunchukus. And even more, it's about what that meant to folks who were seeing those folks with the nunchakus. It wasn't until 2018 that these states finally began to repeal their bans. But even as the government tried to ban nunchucks, they couldn't stop them from influencing culture. The kung fu movies sort of somewhat ride, you know, in the wave of the black exploitation movies. But then the kung fu movies sort of feed back into black culture as well. Can you talk about the adoption of the sort of kung fu aesthetic and things like that in black and hip-hop culture?
所以这告诉你，问题不在于双节棍本身。而在于那些拿着双节棍的人。更重要的是，这对于那些看到这些人拿着双节棍的人来说意味着什么。直到2018年，这些州才终于开始废除禁令。但即使政府试图禁止双节棍，也无法阻止它们对文化产生影响。功夫电影有点像是在搭乘黑人剥削电影的顺风车。但随后功夫电影又反过来滋养了黑人文化。你能谈谈黑人和嘻哈文化中对这种功夫美学及类似事物的接纳吗？
Yeah. It's like young black and brown kids in the inner cities who are discovering these kung fu movies and they're going crazy. you know, and it continues, right? It continues all through the 80s and the 90s. And in 1993, right, like 20 years after Enter the Dragon, we get Wu-Tang Clan, you know? Bruce Lee made a huge impact. He and his nunchucks represented a huge change in the way that the world saw Asian Americans and how they saw themselves, which is pretty remarkable, given how short his life actually was. Bruce Lee died in 1973 when he was only 32 years old, at the peak of his career, only a few months after Enter the Dragon was released.
是的。就像内城区的年轻黑人和棕色人种孩子发现了这些功夫电影，然后他们为之疯狂。你知道的，而且这种影响一直在持续，对吧？它在整个80年代和90年代一直延续着。而在1993年，也就是《龙争虎斗》上映20年后的好时候，我们有了武当帮，你知道吗？李小龙产生了巨大的影响。他和他的双节棍代表了世界看待亚裔美国人以及他们看待自己方式的巨大转变，考虑到他短暂的一生，这相当了不起。李小龙于1973年去世，年仅32岁，正值他事业的巅峰，就在《龙争虎斗》上映几个月后。
The official cause of death was an allergic reaction to equiogesic, a prescription painkiller that he'd taken earlier that evening to treat a headache, and he died from swelling to the brain. I wonder if you thought about what would have happened to Bruce Lee if he hadn't died so young. I do. I do wonder about that. I think about it actually a lot. I think about it in the context, too, in terms of representation. And I think about how it took almost 50 years for us to get to a place where you could have Michelle Yo receive an Academy Award in a role in which she could represent all these different ways that we appear. So not just sort of a kick-ass kung fu master, but she could be a bedraggled housewife and laundromat owner. And she could play literally dozens of different types of roles and represent the broad range of what Asian Americans and Pacific Islanders are. And it hurts me that it's taken that long for us to be able to kind of get to that particular point.
官方死因是对一种名为equiogesic的处方止痛药产生过敏反应，他那天早些时候曾服用该药来治疗头痛，他因脑部肿胀而死。我想知道你是否想过，如果李小龙没有那么年轻就去世，他会怎么样？我会的。我确实想过这个问题。其实我经常这样想。我在代表性的语境下也会考虑到这一点。我想象着，我们花了将近50年的时间才走到今天这一步，让杨紫琼能够凭借一个角色荣获奥斯卡奖，在这个角色中，她可以展现我们呈现自己的所有不同方式。不仅是那种厉害的功夫大师，她还可以是一个衣衫褴褛的家庭主妇和自助洗衣店老板。她可以扮演字面意义上几十种不同类型的角色，代表亚裔美国人和太平洋岛民的广阔范围。一想到我们花了这么长时间才走到这个特定的点，我就感到心痛。
I like to think that had Bruce lived, that he might have been able to move away from just being a martial artist and that he could have been able to explore all of these different types of things. that represented the breath of his humanity. It kind of makes me a little melancholy thinking about that. It's devastating to imagine this, this alternate reality where Bruce Lee doesn't die at 32, where he keeps working and keeps shifting culture at the same time. Perhaps there would have been a time sooner or later where he could have set the nunchucks down,
我喜欢这样想：如果李小龙还活着，他可能已经摆脱了仅仅作为一名武术家的限制，能够去探索所有这些代表他人性广度的不同事物。想到这里，我甚至有点伤感。想象这样一个平行时空是令人心碎的：在这个时空里，李小龙在32岁时没有去世，他继续工作，同时继续改变着文化。也许在不久的将来，总有一天他可以放下双节棍，
that he would no longer have to win people over by fighting. Jeff Chang is the author of Water Mirror, Echo, Bruce Lee, and the Making of Asian America. He's also the author of The Classic, Can't Stop, Won't Stop, A History of the Hip-Ont-Stop, A History of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Ellie Lightfoot.
他不再需要通过打斗来赢得人们的支持。杰夫·陈是《水镜、回声、李小龙与亚裔美国的塑造》一书的作者。他还是《经典之作：永不停歇，历史的……》的作者。……《美国历史与100件物品》是99% Invisible和BBC Studios联合制作的节目。由我罗曼·马尔斯主持和策划。本集由埃利·莱特富特制作。
Our other producers are Priscilla Aalabi and Brenna Dahldorf. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell.
我们的其他制片人是普里西拉·阿拉比和布雷娜·达尔多夫。我们的副制片人是艾萨克·费舍尔。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔剪辑，查理·布兰登·金混音。事实核查由艾米·布雷肯完成。我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔创作。来自99% Invisible，我们的执行制片人是凯茜·2。来自BBC Studios，我们的执行制片人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。
Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的制作协调员是香·帕莱，制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特。插图由斯特凡·劳伦斯绘制。99% Invisible是Serious XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰上城。BBC Studios总部位于西伦敦美丽的白城。如果您想与我们联系或有物品让我们考虑，请发邮件至100 Objects at 99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。